all right happy happy football Monday
everybody it is the the first Monday of
the football season so that's pretty
exciting I hope that your team fared
well yesterday as you were watching the
action my my Baltimore Ravens managed to
squeak out a 59 to 10 victory so that
was pretty exciting to watch you know I
do just want to say this as we enter
into football season that I think it's
important to note that it is our
patriotic duty as Americans to watch and
enjoy football there is no excuse I
don't want to hear this stuff of oh I'm
not a football fan that is that is
unacceptable in America these days Amer
fall is America's pastime it is our most
sacred tradition it has completely
supplanted baseball in those categories
it's not even close anymore I mean we
aren't even the best America is not even
the best at baseball in the world
anymore and basketball has also gone
international but football our football
is well that just belongs to us it's our
thing so think about it football
involves large men crashing into each
other at fast speeds is unique to us in
America and it stole its name from a
lame international version and then
improved it so that is it is
quintessentially American and the most
American thing about it is that we
invented this new sport and we were like
well what are we gonna call it and we
said we'll call it football and the rest
of the world said you can't call it
football we already have a thing called
football you can't and we said now it's
we're gonna call it I don't care let's
just work we're gonna take that were
just gonna call it that and then they
said but you don't even really use your
feet you DS I mean with our football
you're kicking the ball with your feet
so for you to call football doesn't make
any sense and we said yeah but we're
gonna call it anyway doesn't matter
doesn't matter if it doesn't make sense
try and stop us and then we took it and
we turn it into a billion dollar
industry and then we decided we said you
know what you know what every football
team needs is we need to hire a
full-time staff of attractive women who
just stand on the sidelines their only
job is to cheer on the men and so we did
and so that's a thing too I mean how can
you it's it's it is it is some well
someone who doesn't like football I have
to question I do have to question their
patriotism their loyalty and and that's
that's all there is to it all right so
there's a lot to discuss today
and we're gonna get into you know
unfortunately we have to start on a
Monday by talking about some of the baby
killing enthusiasts over on the
Democratic side because they're at it
again
embarrassing themselves and the country
and so we're going to talk about that
but before we do first a word from a
stamps.com you know no one really has
time to go to the post office you're
busy you got all this stuff you got to
do and who has time for the traffic and
for parking and lugging all your mail
and packages nobody it's time for that
so that's why you need stamps calm one
of the most popular time-saving tools
for small businesses stamps.com
eliminates trip trips to the post office
and it saves you money with discounts
that you can't even get at the post
office so it's a win-win-win for you
stamps calm brings all the amazing
services of the u.s. post office right
to your computer whether you're a small
business sending invoices you're an
online seller shipping out product
you're a large warehouse whatever you
are stamps comm can handle all your
issues with ease you can print official
US passage
postage passage postage 24/7 for any
letter any package any class of mail
anywhere you want to send it once your
mail is ready just hand it to your mail
carrier or drop it in a mailbox it
really is that simple now right now this
is the important part my listeners get a
special offer that includes a four week
trial plus free postage and a digital
scale without any long-term commitment
you'd have to go to stamps comm click on
the microphone at the top of the home
page type in Walsh and you could get all
those deals that's stamps comm enter
Walsh alright so as I said let's begin
with the baby killing enthusiasts we've
got a few items to discuss related to
this to this to these these these people
first noted abortion lover Pete Buddha
judge was on the radio show of The
Breakfast Club a couple days ago and he
took the opportunity to launch into
another one of his trademark sermons and
there's this one is is more disturbing
than usual so let's let's watch a bit of
this so what's the reckoning between the
GOP and Christianity well gops got to
deal with the fact that they've come on
board with the president that is
confident Lee against not just our
values but their own right I mean
if you're if you're in Mike Pence's
world where you know being Christian has
a lot to do with with you know kind of
rigid traditional sexual ethics like
that's not stop right there for just a
minute because yet again he goes in with
the Mike Pence thing I mean this guy is
absolutely obsessed with Mike Pence
he must have Mike Pence posters hung up
in his bedroom he's probably as a Mike
Pence cardboard cutout in the middle of
his living room he probably spends his
time writing poems about Mike Pence in
his diary every question he's a hessed
he can be asked the question about so
what's your opinion on you know the
situation in North Korea well you know
the thing about that is Mike Pence dude
take it easy this if I was Mike Pence
I'd be getting a restraining order I
would be seriously concerned at this
point this is not normal for you to be
that completely focused on Mike Pence of
all people so Buddha judge brings it
back to Mike Pence but let's let's go
and and if we can get past Mike Pence
and see what else he has to say I mean
if you're if you're in Mike Pence's
world where you know being Christian has
a lot to do with with you know a kind of
rigid traditional sexual ethics like
that's not how I come across oh yeah but
he does and yet he thinks that this
president ought to be the moral as well
as political leader of this country okay
actually stop it right there again
because we haven't even gotten to the
point yet we haven't got to the crux of
the issue yet but here is Buddha judge
mocking pence for pence is supposed
rigid sexual ethics and and where's he
getting that from why are you accusing
pence of having a rigid sexual ethics
well is it I guess it's from the fact
that pence doesn't want to go on lunch
dates with with women who aren't his
wife well whether you consider that
rigid or not and I don't why is Buddha
judge commenting on Pence's
relationships
I mean Budaj which again is just weird
it's just weird Buddha Jude's give it a
rest
about something else I mean next thing
you know Budaj is gonna be bringing up
stuff about Mike Pence that he shouldn't
even know like well you know Mike Pence
had waffles for breakfast this morning I
know because I was staring in his window
with my binoculars but but but-- can you
imagine how buddha judge would react if
mike pence
ever returned the favor and were to make
comments about buddha judges sexual
ethics what if pence were to get up
there and say you know a mayor buddah
judge has has with his libertine sexual
ethics buddha judge would collapse into
tears at that he would be so scandalized
how dare you make comments about my
personal life even though I've been
talking about you incessantly for the
last 19 months all right let's go back
to the video and you got an entire
Republican Party coming on board with
this but I think deep down they know
that this isn't right
meanwhile you got religious traditions
that teach us about the importance of
lifting up the stranger the importance
of lifting up the pour of healing the
sick that you know you I mean you go
through the New Testament for sure and
every other word that comes out of the
mouth of Christ is about things like
helping those in need and you got a
Republican Party dedicated to its
opposite there will be a reckoning over
that now right now they hold everybody
in line with this one kind of piece of
doctrine about abortion right which is
obviously a tough issue for a lot of
people to think through morally then
again you know there's a lot of parts of
the Bible to talk about how life begins
with breath and so even that is
something that we can interpret
differently and approach or take up me
to it but I think no matter where you
think about the kind of cosmic question
of how life begins most Americans can
get on the board with the idea of all
right I might draw the line here you
might draw the line there but the most
important thing is the person who should
be drawing the line is the woman making
the decision absolutely and I think that
if you're a man who's against the boss
and you haven't gotten
woman pregnant it's not mean wife I'm
just saying we've had some slip-ups all
right so that there you go first of all
the other dude they're not sure who that
is but his reason for supporting
abortion is that sometimes he quote
slips up and quote gets the wrong woman
pregnant the wrong woman now if that's
not a sexist comment I mean if that
isn't about the most misogynistic thing
I've seen I've heard him in a long time
then I don't know what is he's saying
the reason he likes abortion is that
sometimes you get the slip up and get
the wrong woman pregnant but Budaj is
just laughs it off yeah I half expected
him to give a fist bump to the guy or
something he has no problem with that if
he really cared about women and he had a
problem with sexism he would have spoken
up and said that's that's not
appropriate but no cuz he was still
think about Mike Pence he was distracted
now in terms of the the theology or lack
thereof
what buddha judge says says here is
completely false of course nowhere does
the Bible affirm this idea that a baby
isn't a baby until birth in fact the
Bible says before you form me in the
womb you knew me so this makes it pretty
clear that God recognizes our humanity
the humanity of all humans from
beginning to end Andy and importantly he
has a plan for all humans and that plan
probably does not involve being murdered
in the womb because if it did then he
never would have created the person to
begin with of you know you know if
that's what God wanted and intended God
is not going to make a human life
intending and wanting and hoping that
the mother will kill the child before
the child is even born
the stuff about the breath in the Bible
this is obviously set in a poetic way
the breath of life God breathes into
human beings gives them the breath of
life
that's what Budaj is referred to
that clearly is not literal nobody
thinks that God is literally leaning
down from heaven like from the clouds
and breathing with his mouth into the
nostrils of a person and that's how they
come to life nobody that is it's rather
beautiful poetic imagery to describe
something that's pretty clear now I'll
tell you what's not just poetic the
Incarnation as Christians that is I
think rather obviously something that we
take literally
and this biblically for a Christian is
the coup de Gras for pro-abortion
talking points I mean this this is it
Jesus Christ was incarnate in the womb
he was he was miraculously conceived in
the womb now he could have come to earth
in in any way that he chose he could
have he could have descended from heaven
the way that he would would eventually
ascend
he could have materialized that of thin
air I mean many different ways it could
have done but he chose to come to earth
through the vessel of human pregnancy so
if you're saying that unborn babies are
subhuman then you are saying that Christ
was at one time subhuman that is your
Christology to use the the theological
term your your Christology is that Jesus
Christ was at one time less than human
but it's a central doctrine of our faith
that Christ was fully man and fully God
the idea of him being less than man and
fully God is heretical to say the least
and it just does not comport with
Christian theology at all this is
something completely separate Christ
elevated all of mankind but by becoming
men thus he elevated fetuses to by
becoming one
so if abortion wasn't wrong before the
Incarnation which it was it certainly is
afterwards as all of human life
including from the fetal stage was
elevated sanctified by by the
Incarnation this is I mean this is
something that
when we're having the the theological
argument about abortion among Christians
and often times I hear Christians cite
verses from the Old Testament the Ten
Commandments they the one that I cited
before you form you the womb I knew you
Jeremiah and those are all good things
to cite I mean the Ten Commandments thou
shalt not kill that's pretty pretty
solid and obviously it applies to
abortion but I think from a Christian
perspective this should be the first
thing I don't know why this isn't
brought up more often I think the
Incarnation you want to say you want to
say well there's nothing in there by
there's no pro-life statement in the
Bible the Incarnation is about the most
pro-life statement you could the God
could possibly make and it just makes it
so it's it it ends the discussion from a
Christian perspective there's nowhere to
go from there now on this same general
subject let's go over to the AP which
for whatever reason decided to put out a
big big pro-abortion propaganda video
and this video which I'll show you now
it tells us the sad story of a poor
woman who had to go across state lines
and spend a lot of money to kill her
child and we're supposed to feel very
sorry for her and let's see if it
succeeds in making her sympathetic watch
this what I would learn the hard way is
when you first stop taking first control
that first couple weeks but first like
few days you're your most fertile so I
got pregnant in like early February I
was housing insecure at the time like I
just started a job I didn't have any
support
health care I said that they would be
able to help me but I had to get there
before I turned 28 weeks and so I had
less than 10 days and they said that my
procedure would cost about ten thousand
five hundred dollars so they know who's
gonna pick them up it's not a decision
to be made lightly
because on top of early I didn't make it
lightly because it was on top of a large
emotional like turning-point like
decision to make in my life
it was a large financial decision to
make now if you're listening on itunes
or on soundcloud and you couldn't see
the video there there were some captions
that I think were relevant to the to the
issue such as the fact that she was 26
weeks pregnant when she went and got
this abortion actually she was probably
about 27 weeks because she said in the
video that she she'd called the when she
called the abortion clinic in New Mexico
she was less than 10 days from the 28th
week cutoff which probably means by the
time she got the abortion she was at 27
weeks but let's just call it 26 weeks
just for the sake of argument 26 at 26
weeks a child has almost a 90% chance of
survival the vast vast vast majority of
babies that are born at 26 weeks and
that does happens all the time it's it's
a it is not an uncommon occurrence to
have a baby that is so premature 90% of
them nearly 90% survive at this point a
baby has all of his vital organs he has
all of his physical features that we
associate with with being human
he has his nervous system he's a baby
he's just a baby
that's you can go into the which my own
our first kids the twins were pretty
much or not twenty six weeks premature
they were born at 30
thirty-five weeks and so they spent a
little bit of time in a NICU the the
infant that the natal I see you I see
you
unit of the hospital where they send
babies who are premature need need help
breathing so I can remember being up in
the NICU unit and seeing babies that
were much more premature than my babies
were and these are just babies these are
not this is not a mass of gelatinous
amorphous cells lying there okay these
are babies they look in everywhere like
babies they are babies they need
temporary medical treatment and in order
to survive and and then most of them
will go on to live normal lives and
they'll have no prolonged medical
effects at all you know they just need
help at the beginning to breathe now
we're told that abortions this late
don't happen unless there's some kind of
catastrophic medical situation I've
heard this many times I'm sure you have
too that hey well women they're not
they're not doing this willy-nilly
they're actually go get an abortion 26
weeks unless unless you know they need
it for for the sake of survival if
there's a threat to the life of the
mother well as I've said many times
there has never actually been a
medically necessary abortion and if
there is a catastrophic medical
situation that happens at 26 weeks or 28
weeks or 30 weeks which does which does
occur then at that point maybe the baby
needs to come out of the woman yes but
there is no reason to kill the baby
ahead of time by that time you have
essentially a fully formed baby so no
matter what if there's a medical problem
that baby needs to come out the woman is
going to have to deliver the baby the
only question is are we going to kill
the baby before it is delivered and
there's no reason to kill the baby ahead
of time but in any case that's not even
the situation here there was no
catastrophe she said that she was
housing insecure which means what she
was living in an apartment or something
and she she had just started a new job
that's it that's what she tells us she
wasn't gonna die
there was no
no serious medical complication
pregnancy wasn't gonna kill her it would
have just been super inconvenient to
have a kid at that point so she killed
it and sure you know if you just started
a new job and and you have a baby that's
that's inconvenient yeah I mean we my my
wife is pregnant now and she's gonna
give birth in the next month or so and
anytime you have a new baby on the scene
there are a lot of inconveniences yes it
can be a very inconvenient thing in a
lot of ways to have a newborn baby
you guys stay up at night it doesn't the
baby's not sleeping well you got to take
off work all these different things got
to go to the doctor a lot lot of
inconveniences that obviously is not a
suitable moral justification for murder
obviously which is why the pro-abortion
people they don't want to talk about it
in terms of convenience what they want
to talk about are these extreme rare
cases medical abnormalities and so on
but here we have an abortion of
convenience at 26 weeks when the baby
had a 90% chance of survival and the AAP
is taking this story and they're proudly
putting it out there and they expect us
to feel sorry for the woman not the baby
just completely deranged absolutely
deranged but I'm I am I guess the point
here is I am grateful to the AAP for
putting this story out there their
intention obviously is is for to promote
abortion but the effect is for any
normal person with it with even
half-formed conscience when you see that
you're gonna think that's that's
terrible that's just wrong I mean there
are so many other options available to
this woman she could have had the baby
she could have put the baby up for
adoption there are other things she
could have done and we should expect her
as a society to explore those other
options the same way we expect a mother
or
father with born children who finds
himself in a situation where they can't
care for the child anymore and that
happens also but what do we say to those
to those parents we say we're very sorry
you're in that situation but you need to
go put the child up for adoption you
need to make sure that you find someone
who can care for that child because what
you cannot do is just leave the kid in
the living room and split town and what
you certainly cannot do is kill them no
matter what situation you're in no
matter how dire your situation is you
cannot kill your child
you have a responsibility to that child
and that responsibility at the very
least requires you to go and make sure
that that someone else is going to care
for the job if we if we have no problem
saying that and putting that kind of
responsibility onto the shoulders of
parents of born children there is no
reason why we can't put that
responsibility onto the shoulders of
parents of unborn children it's the same
idea the same principle and that's all
alright I also wanted to mention this um
Roman Polanski film director and noted
child rapist has a new movie out and the
new movie just won Best Director at the
Venice Film Festival now this to me is
noteworthy especially during the week
and this is why it really caught my eye
during a week when certain Hollywood
stars have been calling for black lists
of anyone in Hollywood who might support
Donald Trump that you know the five or
six people in Hollywood who support
Donald Trump there's been Debra Messing
and other Hollywood celebrities have
been saying we need to blacklist them
and everything well they're trying to
take the moral high ground on Trump
while they continue to support someone
like Roman Polanski Roman Polanski who
let's recall drugged and raped a 13 year
old girl and this is not allegedly or
anything like that he was convicted he
pled guilty actually now he was able to
he was able to plead the charges down to
rather than rape and I think pled it
down to unwanted sexual contact
or something like that pled it down to a
lesser charge but then rather than face
the music and and do whatever time he
was he was gonna he was he was going to
be sentenced if he fled prosecution he
left the country and he has been on the
lam ever since he is a fugitive he is a
fugitive from justice for 40 years now
after raping a child and in spite of
that he has had a successful career in
Hollywood
making movies now apologists for
Hollywood are gonna point out that well
this was the Venice Film Festival not a
Hollywood function so we can't blame
Hollywood for this but it's all related
it's the film industry besides which
Polanski has had no trouble finding top
film stars to appear in his movies
throughout his career people like Jodie
Foster Kate Winslet Christoph Waltz john
c reilly you and mcgregor Adrien Brody
Johnny Depp Ben Kingsley Sigourney
Weaver these are not fringe character
actors that nobody's heard of these are
top names and these are people who have
appeared in a film directed by someone
who they know is a child rapist a
confirmed child rapist and Polanski won
Best Director at the Academy Awards
fifteen years ago
Meryl Streep gave him a standing ovation
Whoopi Goldberg famously defended him
saying well it did it was it wasn't rape
rape she said whatever that means
Polanski is hollywood's guy they loved
him sure he was kicked out of the out of
the Academy last year because they had
to they had no choice with all the me2
stuff going on they they knew they had
to get rid of him and pretend to take
some kind of moral stand but it was all
it was it was a farce considering the
fact that they kicked him out of the
Academy in what was 2018 back in like oh
six or oh seven they they gave him Best
Director and you know
now they want to circle around and say
and say never mind but they still can't
help themselves so he's still getting
awards and he's still he's still getting
people to come star in his movies so
that gesture meant meant nothing from
from the Academy it was a total classic
cya move and nothing more Polanski is as
I said Hollywood's guy let's not forget
that and this is an important thing to
keep in mind as especially as we head
into the 2020 election and we're gonna
be subjected to all kinds of PSAs and
all kinds of lecturing from these people
whether it's about Donald Trump or it's
about climate change or it's about guns
or whatever they're trying to take a
moral stance meanwhile Roman Polanski is
the the big grotesque disgusting child
raping elephant in the room and we
really just I don't to belabor the point
but you really think about this this
this is not one of those things where
we're that where they're continuing to
support Polanski because they can just
claim that he didn't do it it's not one
of those things like the like the people
that still support oj and say uh he
didn't he didn't really do it which
which obviously is absurd he clearly did
it and he's all but admitted it with
roman polanski it he pled guilty
there's no no one is saying he didn't do
it the people who still support him in
hollywood and again these are big names
these are prominent big names they're
still supportive what they must be
saying is not he didn't do it but yeah
he did it but it's okay that's them now
they're not saying that directly Whoopi
Goldberg came as close as anyone's come
to saying indirectly say I wasn't rape
rape um meanwhile not only was she a
child but she was she drugged her and
raped her if that's not rape rape than
what is if you're telling me that that's
not really rape will be gold
then what in in the hell possibly could
be if that doesn't qualify but anyway
what they must be saying is they don't
see a problem with it they're fine with
it with a grown man drugging a 13 year
old child and raping her and that's not
surprising that they feel that way but
it's important to keep in mind these
people are absolute moral degenerates
all right let's see we're gonna get to
emails Matt Walsh show at gmail.com Matt
well showed you actually before we get
before we talk about before I answer
some emails I do I did have one more
issue I wanted to discuss and this is
kind of this is kind of kind of personal
and and you know it's hard for me to
talk about so I apologize but last night
last night I had to run to the store for
something and as I often tend to do when
I'm when I'm just making a late-night
run to the store I went out in my very
stylish though also comfortable
inconvenient socks and sandals combo and
I'll show you a picture because I'm not
ashamed right I'm not ashamed here's a
picture of the of the getup
that I wore to the store now sure it's
it's comfortable as I said it's also
very fashion-forward it's very bold as
you can see well I'm in line checking
out and the dude behind the register
actually makes fun of me
and my Footwear to my face he didn't
even wait till I had gone like any other
self-respecting person just to my face
he makes funny so I go home and I tell
my wife about it hoping that someone
I'll have someone to you know comfort me
in my in my time of this very trying
time and instead she makes fun of me too
and then she actually grabs her phone
and quickly takes a picture of my feet
and text it to her sister so they can
make fun of me together now of course
I'm feeling I'm feeling attacked and
unsafe in my own home Here I am trying
to live my truth trying to stand in my
truth trying to wear my truth and this
is how I'm treated so then I post this
picture on Twitter last night thinking
that okay
now I'm gonna find emotional support
because that's what your Twitter is
known for is you know emotional support
but instead there's just more mockery
and shame and bullying and ridicule
heaped on me and my and my socks and
sandals so I want to say this first of
all the anti socks and sandals bigotry
in this country needs to end our
forefathers came to this country because
they wanted to be able to wear whatever
foot attire they chose and if they could
see if George Washington could see the
way that people with socks and sandals
are treated now he would be rolling over
in his grave second let it be known that
I am an icon in the fashion world I
don't talk about it very often I don't
brag about it
I try to make a big deal about it but
people come up to me all the time all
the time and they say to me Matt I want
to thank you for your bold and beautiful
fashion choices you have changed my life
I mean look at me right now I'm wearing
a you know black some black pullover
with some weird green vomity colored
t-shirt I mean this is this is fashion
folks third thing is for those who say
oh why would you wear socks and sandals
because if you're wearing socks then
just put on shoes and if you're wearing
sandals what's the point in sock well I
explained to you first of all there are
two really good reasons to wear socks
nails
if you already have socks on and you
want to leave the house and you need
some kind of other footwear to put on
and you have sandals right next to the
door but your shoes are all the way
upstairs
that's a good reason and second if your
socks are awesome and you want to show
them off then that's another good reason
though I shouldn't have to justify
myself and I really am tired of the way
that socks and sandals are treated I
swear to get that off my chest now we'll
go to emails Matt wall show at gmail.com
Matt wall show at gmail.com this is from
Matt says from Chuck sorry says Matt you
sound like a communist when you say
college athletes should get paid in a
free market economy those players are
agreeing to sell their label labor for
free tuition a college degree and the
fame of playing the game if they're good
enough
yeah I got a lot of emails like this we
talked about paying players last week on
the show I think on Friday and I feel
pretty strongly that that college
athletes it's at least in the the major
schools and the major sports the sports
that rake in billions of dollars like
for example college football it's the
main thing we're talking about here that
they should get a cut of those profits
now Chuck says that that makes me a
communist well what I'm talking about is
people being paid a fair market value
for for the labor that they provide how
is that communist that is free market
the the college system is a corrupt
rigged system it is a really a rigged
system where the players come in and
they are exploited in every possible
Avenue through ticket sales and
merchandise and TV deals and everything
else and it is set up so that all of
that money is going to go into the
pockets of the coaches and the
administrators and other people who are
not playing these these head coaches
they these major schools they are paid
multiple millions of dollars a year for
coaching football where does that money
come from it's it the money comes from
the people that are going to the games
to watch people that are buying the
merchandise never else that's where the
money's coming from how is it communist
for me to say that everybody involved in
earning that money should see a piece of
it it's the opposite of communist in
fact this system right here this is like
a communist system where it's set up so
that the people of the sort of
administrative roles at the top they're
gonna see all the money and then the
peons at the bottom are they got to be
satisfied with you know free lunch so no
and to say free tuition a college degree
okay great
at most what's that worth let's say at
most you go to $200,000 look at the
upper end about $50,000 a year compared
to a coach who's making 5 million
here and not only that but in order to
play they're not able to actually focus
on their education the colleges might
say oh yeah we want to do the education
first that's not how they feel that's
not what they really want to me it's a
very simple question okay very simple
they these college programs the major
college programs earn billions of
dollars collectively from from these
from these players the question is
should only the people not playing get a
piece of that money or should the people
playing also get a piece I cannot
understand the argument for no no I feel
strongly that only the administrators
and coaches to be millionaires
and-and-and the kids should be satisfied
because they get a free education what
kind of position is that it's so bizarre
to me I don't even understand it why do
you feel so strongly that you know the
head coach should get five million
dollars in the pit the player should we
pay nothing why why if you think you're
protecting the integrity of amateur
sports it's not amateur when you've got
people when they're when there's
billions of dollars being made it's not
amateur it is professional sports when
you can get paid five million dollars a
year or nine million dollars a year as
one head coach in college football's
being paid right now in order to coach
it then that's not amateur anymore that
is professional so III just really don't
get it at the very least I hope you
wouldn't you would agree at the very
least that these kids should be able to
if go out on their own and profit from
their own name because the way it's set
up right now is that yeah these kids get
free housing and free lunch
meanwhile the coaches are making
millions a year and not only that the
players aren't allowed to go out and
sell say their own Jersey or get paid
for a sponsorship or for a TV appearance
they're not a
loud - they get in trouble if a player
is caught and this has happened players
are caught you know sad forbids selling
their own merchandise based on their own
name and they get in trouble for that
and we're supposed to be outraged at
them for trying to profit off of their
own name and not at the system that's
that that that stipulates that the only
people who are allowed to get filthy
rich off of this are the are the the the
the coaches and administrators who are
exploiting these kids for money I that
to me is crazy so at the very least I
hope you would agree that these if if
someone is a top college quarterback and
they're a great player and therefore
their jerseys are worth money and
therefore there are companies that want
to have sponsorship deals with them and
therefore they could get paid for TV /
they should be able to go out and do
that and if you're telling me that you
think they shouldn't be able through
then please don't give me any this
nonsense about how your this is
free-market capitalism this is the
interference in free-market capital this
is the n-c-double-a saying no you're not
you're not allowed to engage in the free
market we're not allowing you to do that
you are not allowed to go make money
we're gonna make millions you are not
allowed to make any again that that is
psychologically I cannot understand what
would lead someone to support I can
understand why the n-c-double-a likes
that system they're getting all the
money they're getting rich but for
someone who's not even involved either
way look what why all right
it's from Jonathan says hey Matt love
the show what are your expectations on
the Raven season this year and are you
as high on Lamar Jackson there's a lot
of Baltimore fans seem to be I'm
originally from Buffalo which means I
have to be a Bills fan I'm hoping hoping
passing on Lamar for Josh Allen wasn't a
mistake
well after that performance yesterday I
mean well Lamar at a perfect passer
rating threw for 300 plus yards five
touchdowns and he made some really good
throws now people could say well that
was Miami Dolphins they're tanking this
year and that's all true but they're
still a professional football team and
they still have a pretty good secondary
and I look I don't you know I don't care
how bad the team is if you can go out
and play like that then that's a good
sign and in fact this is this this is
what good
good teams are supposed to absolutely
trounce bad teams and so winning you
know what was it fourteen fifty nine
fifty nine to zero to ten a fifty nine
to ten that's that's that's a sign that
you're a really good team and you're
also a good player if you can perform
that way against any competition I don't
care if it is the Miami Dolphins this is
from Andrew says there's a lot of
controversy around the idea of open vers
concealed-carry it's a huge point of
debate within the gun community got on
our community my issue with it isn't the
idea of banning open carry but rather
with the banning concealed carry and
states that effectively force you to
open carry the big reason to open carry
is comfort especially with a larger gun
the second biggest advantage is ease of
access if an older person if it's an
older person carrying this way the
former wouldn't surprise me as much even
in my mid-30s my hands are not what they
were in the 20s in my 20s and I can't
imagine what a person in their 50s or
60s would go through there the other
perspective of open carry is the amount
of restrictive nough surround concealed
carry it varies greatly from state to
state but if you accidentally flash a
bit of metal or print excessively it
could be considered brandishing there's
plenty of people see seeing out there
good concealed carry you can make you
can make more than a couple of them but
you have to be paying attention that
said I wouldn't be surprised if you
could carry a 357 around and not get a
lot of notice in states where it was
legal if only because no one can pry
their eyes away from their phones not
really a disagreement one way or another
I found myself on the fence and believed
in the ideas of tact and circumstance
when open carry is in play the exception
being legality as mentioned above I
think a vast vast proportion of the
carry community would respect their
wishes and probably vote with their
dollars yeah those are good points and I
guess I hadn't really addressed we
talked about open carry last week and I
said I I don't really see the point of
it and in all my years I almost never
see people open carry even in states
where it's legal
I've lived in states where it's legal
I've lived in states where you know I
have lived in states where they have
concealed carry and open carry a lot of
the states where they only have okay I
just I rarely ever see it it's just a
very small minority of people who seem
to be to want
open carry and I said last week I can't
I generally can't see why someone would
unless they're just trying to sort of
show off that they have a gun and
they're wearing it as a fashion
statement
now Andrew brings up some points of
reasons why someone might open carry for
legitimate reasons and so I take that
point I guess there are some legitimate
reasons there but we also can't deny
that you know it's true that most gun
owners are responsible as I said last
week most gun owners are responsible
mature and all of that they treat the
gun they respect the firearm as they see
it as a tool they understand that it can
be dangerous if misused and so they have
a proper respect for it
that's most gun owners that's not every
gun owner though and there are there are
some people and I think this is also a
problem it's a minority but there are
some people in the gun owning community
who just are way too impressed with
their guns and and they do see it as a
fashion that they think they're cool for
having that's why they take the whole
thing this is a sort of a separate issue
not a big deal but the people who take
pictures of themselves you know like
like you know the people if you go on
faced with all of their pictures or them
with their guns everything you know that
to me sometimes can come across like
you're treating it like a bit of a toy
now if you have one or two pictures of
you with the gun I'm not saying there's
a problem with that I'm just saying
there are some people who are constantly
taking pictures themselves posing with
the gun like they're James Bond or
something that makes me uncomfortable
and when I see the the open carry it
kind of sometimes seems to be in that
vein of people who are too impressed
with it and the reason why it's so
noticeable is that it is very different
from the attitude and the approach that
the vast majority of gun owners have so
that's my issue but all of that aside
even if there are legitimate reasons to
open carry can I take your point that
there can be the point still remains the
main point we talked about last week is
that if that I think it's perfectly
reasonable for individual stores and
establishments and companies to say okay
maybe you could do it out there we don't
want you to do it in here I think it's
reasonable for them to say and we as gun
owners have to respect that and we
should respect it alright so we will
leave it there thanks everybody for
watching
Godspeed the Matt Walsh show is produced
by Robert Sterling associate producer
alexia Garcia Del Rio executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer his
Austin Stevens edited by Donovan Fowler
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mena the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright day Lee Weyer 2019
hey everybody its Andrew Clavin host of
the Andrew Clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
American Republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching and the moon is
turned to blood but on the Andrew Clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the Andrew
Clavin show and laugh your way through
the apocalypse with me Andrew Clayton